[Musique]
notre avenir
propre vert prospère uni
confiant et ambitieux et c'est le
prix
et c'est notre responsabilité nous
serons le lit de semence
pour les investissements commerciaux les plus excitants et les plus dynamiques
de la planète
[Musique]
et il n'y aura rien de plus  dangereux
pour le nouvel avenir
que nous voulons construire que d'autoriser la
possibilité permanente
de prolonger la période de mise en œuvre
dans une torture dont
nous nous souvenons tous, Prométhée enchaîné au
rocher tartare, son foie picoré par un aigle,
puis repoussant en tant que
membres honorables de tous les côtés de
la maison se souviendra et repoussera ensuite
pour être à nouveau picorée
dans le cycle répété pour toujours
[Musique]
déclaration d'ordre le premier ministre,
notre mission est de réaliser le Brexit
le 31 octobre dans le but
d'unir et de redynamiser
notre grand pays uni  royaume et faire de ce
pays
le meilleur endroit au monde et c'est
notre responsabilité, à la Chambre des
communes, de le remplir et pour ce faire, nous devons
prendre
des mesures immédiates. La première est de
restaurer la confiance
dans notre démocratie et de tenir les
promesses répétées du Parlement
de  les gens en sortant de l'
union européenne
et en le faisant le 31 octobre
je préférerais que nous quittions l'ue avec un
accord je le
préférerais de loin je crois que c'est
possible même à ce stade tardif et
je travaillerai d'arrache-pied
pour  pour que cela se réalise, mais certaines
choses doivent être claires.
L'accord de retrait négocié par
mon prédécesseur
a été rejeté à trois reprises par cette
Assemblée.
Ses conditions sont inacceptables pour ce
parlement
et pour ce pays. Aucun pays qui
valorise son indépendance et qui se respecte lui-même ne
pourrait accepter un  traité qui a mis
fin à notre indépendance économique
et à notre autonomie
constitutionnelle, j'ai pensé que
je m'excuse d'avoir interrompu le premier
ministre, il y a beaucoup trop de
bruit dans cette salle et beaucoup trop de
députés qui pensent que c'est normal qu'ils
crient leur opinion au premier ministre  Monsieur
le ministre, soyons
clairs, la
déclaration ne sera pas entendue
et il y aura amplement d'occasions,
conformément
à la convention et comme je l'ai établi
au cours de la dernière
décennie, pour que mes collègues interrogent le
premier ministre,
le premier ministre, monsieur le président, il y a
toutes les chances que  en 2050
et j'ai bien l'intention d'être là,
même si pas nécessairement dans ce travail,
nous pourrons considérer
cette période extraordinaire comme le
début d'un nouvel
âge d'or pour notre Royaume-Uni.
Merci, merci, Monsieur le Président
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président, je salue la position du très
honorable monsieur
et je le remercie pour une
copie avancée
de sa déclaration. Personne ne sous-estime
ce pays mais le pays
[Applaudissements] l'
est,
mais le pays est profondément inquiet
que le nouveau Premier ministre
se surestime
[Applaudissements]  ]
il hérite d'un pays freiné
par neuf ans d'austérité
j'ai indiqué que les gens ne crieraient pas
sur le premier ministre c'est
pareil pour le chef
de l'opposition
n'essayez pas vous gaspillez vos
cordes vocales et surtout  tout
cela ne marchera pas jeremy corbyn
merci monsieur le président si le premier
ministre
continue de poursuivre un non-accord imprudent
accepte-t-il qu'il bafouerait directement
la volonté exprimée de ce parlement le
secteur de l'industrie et les syndicats ont été
absolument clairs
sur la menace qui  cela pose que le Royaume-Uni
représente une grande partie de l'
industrie manufacturière et dit qu'aucun accord ne
serait le comble de la folie économique,
monsieur le président, ceux qui prônent imprudemment l'absence d'
accord
ne seront pas ceux qui perdront
l'élite riche qui le finance et
son parti ne perdra pas son emploi.
leur niveau de vie diminue ou ils font face à
des factures alimentaires plus élevées,
monsieur le Président,
prends le temps qu'il faut, j'ai tout
le temps, je ne suis absolument pas gêné par ces
questions,
Jeremy Corbyn, il dit qu'il a du courage
et de l'ambition,
notre pays n'a pas besoin d'agiter ses bras
[  Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fanfaronnades
[Applaudissements]
ordre pour éviter tout doute il
n'y a pas de vote sur un projet de loi
ce soir il y a un vote sur une motion et
si cette motion est adoptée il y
aura un projet de loi
demain ordre je dis ceci simplement  parce que
l'intelligibilité de nos débats
pour ceux qui les observent
est importante et je suis sûr que tout le monde, de
tous les côtés de la Chambre, reconnaîtrait
cette vérité fondamentale qui
dirige l'opposition jeremy corbyn,
monsieur le président, le premier ministre a rencontré les dirigeants de l'ue
au cours de l'été
et le président du conseil de l'ue  tusk au
g7
après ces réunions, le premier ministre a
adopté une
note optimiste en disant que les chances d'un accord étaient
dans ses paroles
améliorant son optimisme n'était pas partagé par
ceux qui ont assisté aux mêmes
réunions. les dirigeants de l'ue rapportent que le
gouvernement n'a pas réussi jusqu'à présent
à  présenter de nouvelles propositions
le journal interne du
parti conservateur, autrement connu sous le nom de Daily
Telegraph,
rapporte que le chef de cabinet du premier ministre
qualifie les négociations de
trompe-l'oeil et que la stratégie consiste à citer des citations en retard,
aucun accord, monsieur le
président,
signifiera une réduction des pénuries alimentaires  fournitures médicales
et chaos dans nos ports, ce n'est pas moi, ce n'est
pas moi qui dis que l'
analyse divulguée du gouvernement dit
et met en garde contre le chaos à tous les
niveaux.
Nous arrivons maintenant à la motion au nom de
Sir Oliver Lewin, c'est la dernière semaine
au cours de laquelle le Parlement va  avoir la
capacité de bloquer une sortie sans accord le
31 octobre,
le Premier ministre est dans la
position
de quelqu'un se tenant d'un côté d'un
canyon
criant aux gens de l'autre côté
du canyon que s'ils ne font pas ce qu'il
souhaite
il se jettera dans l'abîme,
ce qui n'est pas une stratégie de négociation crédible. Il est
temps de prendre une décision. Si les honorables députés
de l'autre côté de la Chambre
veulent empêcher une sortie sans accord le
31 octobre,
ils auront la possibilité de le faire
si,
mais seulement s'ils votent pour  cette motion
ce soir
j'espère qu'ils le feront
le leader de la Chambre M. Jacob Reese
Mogg euh merci euh
monsieur le Président c'est un
plaisir de prendre la parole dans ce débat
euh présenté par le très honorable
monsieur le député de Dorset West
ce gouvernement  est absolument déterminé
à réaliser le Brexit le 31
octobre,
nous devons délivrer le plus grand mandat démocratique
de l'histoire du pays, pour obtenir le
résultat du référendum, il faut que cette Chambre
respecte la voix du peuple telle
qu'exprimée lors de ce vote historique
et jusqu'à présent, la Chambre n'a pas réussi à le faire  faites-le,
monsieur le Président, je tiens à être clair, ce qui
est proposé aujourd'hui est
constitutionnellement
irrégulier. Je remercie le très honorable
député d'avoir cédé maintenant. Je suis fier d'
avoir mon nom ici,
très fier de me tenir aux côtés de gens qui sont
prêts à faire passer le
pays avant le parti.  pays avant moi,
je n'ai pas été envoyé ici par mes électeurs pour les
appauvrir et
mettre en danger leur emploi et leurs
soins de santé
et je pense que c'est notre priorité absolue
que nous soyons ici pour mettre fin à un Brexit sans accord,
il ne s'agit pas de savoir si nous  sont des restants
ou des Brexiters,
beaucoup de gens qui ont voté pour le Brexit
continueraient de le faire, mais pas pour un
Brexit sans accord. Je crois qu'il
n'y a pas de majorité dans le pays ou dans cette
Assemblée
pour un Brexit sans accord, ce qui est un désastre
pour les autres personnes de cette région.  pays,
je pense que l'honorable dame présente un
argument très passionné, monsieur le Président,
l'essentiel est qu'il s'agit d'
idéologie et quelle que soit la manière dont les gens ont voté lors du
référendum sur le Brexit,
ils n'ont certainement pas voté pour cela, oui
et quand on considère que le Trésor
a publié un document en dernier  année
qui a montré qu'un Brexit audio pourrait
réduire le PIB sur une période de 15 ans
de près de 10 pour cent.
Arrêtez-vous là-dessus,
vous parlez d'un impact sur l'
économie quatre fois plus important
que la crise économique de 2008,
la crise économique qui est  a inauguré une
décennie d'austérité,
le gouvernement insiste pour poursuivre
une politique à
laquelle il sait qu'une majorité
au Parlement est opposée.
Je pense qu'il n'y a pas de président
pour cela, je pense à mon très
honorable ami, le leader de la
Chambre
est très  bon pour garder un visage impassible
lorsqu'il présente
des arguments presque incroyables selon lesquels
je laisserai de côté les avantages du commerce uniquement au sein de l'OMC,
euh, je suis sûr que les Nord-Coréens prospèrent
grâce à cela de toutes les
manières imaginables, sauf l'idée
qu'au moment d'une telle
crise historique, des décisions si importantes
que la Chambre peut être confrontée à
des arguments de ce genre,
c'est toute la faute des Allemands, des
Français et en particulier des
commissaires,
toute la faute du Parlement et euh, ayez
une renonciation rapide aux élections Union Jack
et  ensuite, nous réglerons les problèmes
qui surviendront
lorsque nous aurons quitté la raison pour laquelle nous ne pouvons pas
obtenir de majorité pour quoi que ce soit ici
et nous reflétons exactement le
parlement public, vous savez,
la confusion paralysée, je pense,
reflète entièrement la division du  public
où il n'y a pas de majorité claire pour
quoi que ce soit,
mais la seule chose pour laquelle nous avons une majorité
jusqu'à présent est que nous sommes contre une sortie
sans accord,
mais trois ans et demi plus tard,
il est parfaitement évident pour beaucoup d'entre
nous que ce pays
va  Malheureusement, une
partie de mon parti a été
détournée par un secteur restreint
de ceux qui ont voté pour partir et qui
utilisent simplement la volonté du peuple comme
instrument
de tyrannie potentielle envers tous
ceux
qui ne sont pas d'accord avec lui.  ce gouvernement
n'a aucun mandat pour la forme vicieuse de
Brexit
qu'il poursuit, cela n'a jamais été inscrit sur les
bulletins de vote,
maintenant on a beaucoup parlé de
démocratie ce soir et le
leader de la Chambre que je dois dire
avec son langage corporel tout au long de cette
soirée a  été
si méprisant à l'égard de cette Chambre
et pour le bénéfice du hansard, le
leader de la Chambre a été
réparti sur trois sièges
allongés comme si c'était quelque chose de très
ennuyeux à écouter
ce soir. Plus que cela, cela signifie aussi
un cauchemar pour les gens de  Irlande du Nord,
je rends hommage
à l'honorable député de North
Dan qui a fait valoir ce point
tant de fois
[Musique]
comment osons-nous, dans cette salle, penser que
nous allons
déchirer l'accord du Vendredi Saint et penser
que ce n'est rien à faire  préoccupé par
tout ce dont il faut s'inquiéter,
la question est la motion
comme sur le journal au nom
de Sir Oliver Letwin autant que ceux qui sont de
cette opinion
disent que je
du pays maintenant
[Musique]
lobby
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le  les yeux à droite 328
le nez à gauche 301.
[Applaudissements]
pas un bon début Morris ordonne les yeux
à droite
328 le nez à gauche
301 donc les yeux l'ont
les yeux l'ont déverrouillé
[Musique]
monsieur le haut-parleur à propos du  Conséquences de
ce vote de ce soir,
cela signifie que le Parlement est sur le point
de détruire tout accord que nous
pourrions conclure
à Bruxelles, car le projet de loi de demain
confierait le contrôle des négociations
à l'UE, ce qui entraînerait davantage de
divergences, plus de retards, plus de confusion
et  cela signifierait que l'UE elle-même
serait en mesure de décider combien de temps le
pays restera dans l'UE
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas de consentement dans cette Assemblée pour
quitter l'Union européenne sans
accord il n'y a pas de majorité
pour l'absence d'accord dans le pays
si  le Premier ministre a confiance
dans sa politique en matière de Brexit,
quand il en a une qu'il peut proposer, il
devrait la soumettre
au peuple lors d'un vote public
[Applaudissements]
je dis au chancelier du duché
que lorsqu'il se présentera à l'
école de nos enfants comme  un parent c'est
un gars très bien élevé
il n'oserait pas se comporter comme ça
devant Colin Hall et je ne gesticulerais pas non plus ne divague pas
épargne-nous
le théâtre
comporte-toi sois un bon garçon jeune homme
sois un bon garçon trouve  le mystère du matin
et le merle
ne nous donnent pas ce fantasme absurde
selon lequel il y a un accord à venir du
gouvernement, ce n'est tout simplement
pas vrai le gouvernement doit respecter la
souveraineté de la Chambre du Parlement
doit permettre que le projet de loi soit adopté doit
permettre  il faut avoir le consentement royal
et oui, organisons des élections, mais
organisons des élections
qui respectent la démocratie de cette
Chambre et le désir des
parlementaires de
s'assurer que nous ne nous effondrons pas sur
une base audio,
je ne vais pas  en fait, je ne vais pas me faire
crier dessus, surtout par qui que ce soit,
monsieur le Président, le vote de ce soir a fait s'asseoir même le
leader de la Chambre,
la rumeur est que chaque
membre du parti conservateur qui a
voté contre son gouvernement ce soir aura
le droit  le fouet leur est retiré
[Applaudissements]
Monsieur le Président, si c'est le cas,
ce doit être la première fois et cela impliquerait
des membres honorables et très honorables
qui ont servi leur parti et
beaucoup diraient que leur pays pendant des décennies,
le Premier ministre pourrait-il
confirmer qu'ils auront le droit  whip
retiré
oui ou non
[Musique]
collègues je voudrais faire une
déclaration personnelle à la Chambre
lors des élections de 2017
j'ai promis à ma femme et à mes enfants
que ce serait ma dernière
c'est un engagement que j'ai l'intention de tenir
j'ai servi comme député  député
depuis 22 ans
et depuis
dix ans en tant que président, cela
a été,
permettez-moi de le dire explicitement, le plus grand
privilège et honneur de ma vie professionnelle
pour lequel je serai éternellement
[Applaudissements]
reconnaissant
oui au revoir
monsieur le président les seigneurs qui sont autorisés
par  la commission de sa majesté
de déclarer
sa sanction royale aux actes adoptés par les deux
chambres
et de déclarer également la progression du
Parlement
désirer la présence de ce
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je reconnais que notre présence est souhaitée
par
le  majesté des commissaires de la reine,
ce n'est cependant pas une prorogation normale,
ce n'est pas typique,
ce n'est pas standard, c'est l'une des
plus longues
depuis des décennies et elle représente non seulement
dans l'esprit de nombreux collègues,
mais aussi un grand nombre de personnes extérieures à
un pouvoir exécutif actif et, par conséquent,
je suis un dirigeant actif de Fiat, M. Stewart,
si vous ne l'aimez pas, vous avez parfaitement
droit à votre point de vue,
je ne pourrais pas donner à un flamant volant quel
est votre point de vue,
merci beaucoup, merci
beaucoup, en effet, ouais,
faites votre travail dans lequel  vous payez généreusement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce jeu de mots a refusé
trois fois d'adopter une loi de retrait
et lorsque ce gouvernement tire la seule
conclusion logique de cette position, qui est qu'il
doit partir, donc sans aucun
accord,
il continue de fixer  son visage refuse à l'
électorat la possibilité
de lui faire dire
comment ces questions doivent être résolues
ce parlement
est un parlement mort il
ne devrait plus siéger il n'a aucun
droit moral de s'asseoir sur ces bancs verts
et quoi qu'il en soit
ce parlement est une honte
ils  Je pourrais accepter une motion pour permettre à
cette Chambre de se dissoudre,
mais ils sont trop lâches,
mais le moment vient, le moment
vient, monsieur le Président,
où même ces dindes
ne pourront pas empêcher Noël,
monsieur Barry Sherman, monsieur le Président, je
suis entré dans la chambre.  Aujourd'hui, je pensais que je
me sentais désolé
pour le procureur général, mais dès qu'il a
commencé,
j'ai fait assez juste, mais chaque mot qu'il a
prononcé n'a aucune honte aujourd'hui, aucune honte,
ce gouvernement a cyniquement
manipulé la prorogation pour fermer
cette maison
afin qu'il ne puisse pas travailler comme procureur général.  assemblée démocratique,
il sait que c'est la vérité et
venir ici avec ses avocats fanfaronner
pour obscurcir la vérité et pour un homme
comme lui,
un parti comme celui-ci et un leader comme celui-ci,
ce premier ministre
parle de morale et de moralité
est une honte pour
beaucoup de  ceux qui ont voté en faveur de la
loi sur la capitulation il y a quelques semaines ont
déclaré que le Parlement devait voter contre
tout accord,
par pur égoïsme et par
lâcheté politique.
Les députés d'en face ne sont pas disposés à s'écarter et à donner la parole
au peuple.  nous a envoyé
ici
ce soir, le Premier ministre a
continuellement utilisé un
langage péjoratif pour décrire une loi
du Parlement
adoptée par cette Chambre, nous ne devrions pas
recourir à un langage offensant, dangereux
ou incendiaire pour une législation
que nous n'aimons pas
et nous nous tenons ici, Monsieur le Président, sous
le bouclier  de notre ami décédé
avec beaucoup d'entre nous dans cet endroit soumis chaque jour à des
menaces de mort et à des abus
et permettez-moi de dire au
Premier ministre qu'ils citent souvent ses
paroles,
abandonnez-vous, trahison, traître
comme moi, pour ma part, j'en ai marre, nous devons
modérer notre  langage et cela doit d'abord venir
du Premier ministre,
je serais intéressé d'entendre
son opinion, il devrait avoir absolument
honte de lui-même,
je pense, monsieur le président, je dois vous le dire, monsieur le président, je je dois
dire, monsieur le président, je n'ai jamais
entendu une telle connerie  dans toute ma vie
[Musique]
je pense que cet accord représente
une très bonne affaire à la fois pour l'UE et pour le
Royaume-Uni. Je suis tout à fait d'accord, Jean-Claude, avec ce que vous avez dit sur la protection du processus de paix sur l'île
d'Irlande et en Irlande.  l'Irlande du Nord et
bien sûr pour nous au Royaume-Uni, cela signifie que
nous pouvons proposer un véritable Brexit qui
atteint nos objectifs et cela signifie
que le Royaume-Uni
partira entier le 31 octobre.
Je dois dire que je suis content de l'
accord mais  je suis triste
du Brexit, passe un bon moment
[Musique]
c'est un projet de loi d'une importance et d'une complexité énormes,
il décidera de l'avenir de notre pays
et de l'avenir
de notre économie et du modèle économique
que nous suivons
avec les plus grands cerveaux du monde
et je suis sûr que cette Chambre contient les
plus grands cerveaux du monde, il ne fait aucun
doute que 17 heures, ce n'est pas beaucoup
pour traiter 40 articles et 110
pages de ce projet de loi, Monsieur le Président, le
Premier ministre essaie de prendre
ce Parlement
par surprise.  forcer cet accord et ce
Parlement doit le mettre au défi de le faire
[Musique]
Monsieur le Président, je sais que toute la Chambre
voudra se joindre à moi pour enregistrer qu'après
10 années tumultueuses, ce sont les dernières
questions de votre Premier ministre
et comme il sied à un ancien
concurrent distingué de Wimbledon
vous êtes assis là, dans votre chaise haute,
et pas seulement en tant qu'arbitre,
statuant impitoyablement sur les subtilités de la
procédure parlementaire avec votre
crâne de Tony Montana,
monsieur le président, non seulement en tant que commentateur,
mais surtout en tant qu'acteur à part entière,
pimentant chaque partie  de la chambre avec
vos propres
pensées et opinions, comme une
machine à balles de tennis, une
machine à balles de tennis incontrôlable, monsieur le président,
et alors que nous arrivons à la fin de ce qui doit
être la plus longue retraite depuis Frank
Sinatra,
monsieur le président, je suis sûr que toute la maison
voudra  Joignez-vous à moi pour vous remercier
et espérer que vous profiterez pendant votre
retraite du médicament apaisant
que vous nous avez souvent prescrit au
reste d'entre nous.
[Applaudissements]
J'invite Sir Lindsay Hoyle à prendre le
fauteuil de la Chambre
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas d'applaudissements ouais
[Applaudissements]
donc
c'est un plaisir pour Sa Majesté que vous,
membres de la Chambre des communes,
repassez en revue l'endroit où vous devez vous asseoir
et procédez là au choix
d'une personne appropriée pour être votre orateur,
donc
[Applaudissements]
Premier ministre
orateur  Je ne veux absolument pas manquer de respect
à ceux qui ne sont plus parmi nous, Monsieur le
Président, mais je pense
que ce Parlement constitue une grande
amélioration par
rapport à son prédécesseur et, en effet, Monsieur le Président,
je dirais que c'est l'un des meilleurs
parlements que ce pays ait jamais
produits,
avec plus de femmes parmi ses membres.  que jamais
auparavant,
avec plus de membres noirs et ethniques minoritaires
que jamais auparavant
et c'est aussi, monsieur le président, et j'ai
incarné en votre personne, monsieur le président,
un parlement beaucoup plus démocratique
parce que ce parlement ne fera pas
perdre le temps de la nation dans l'impasse
et la division et  retard vendredi de cette
semaine ce parlement va mettre l'
accord de retrait
vendredi dans le dans
le plongeon comme on dit au Pays de Galles et
ensuite ce nouveau parlement démocratique ce
parlement populaire
va faire quelque chose monsieur le président je
pourrais juste en être
un  d'après vous, vous pouvez deviner ce que
ce parlement va faire, que va-t-il
faire, c'est que monsieur le président
ne fasse pas attention, monsieur le président, je veux que
vous deviniez ce que ce parlement
va faire une fois que nous aurons remis le retrait
de l'accord
à nous  je vais avoir le Brexit
je pense que même je pense que même votre même
votre perroquet
euh monsieur l'orateur aurait pu
citer celui-là
les yeux à droite 330 le nez à
gauche
231 point d'ordre monsieur ian blackford
merci madame  vice-président, c'est
la première fois
qu'il fait partie de l'union, un pays de
l'union,
car il a subi quelque chose qui lui est
reproché,
madame la vice-présidente, il s'agit d'une
crise constitutionnelle,
car nous n'accepterons pas et nous ne pouvons pas accepter
ce qui nous a été fait et  Je dis au
Premier ministre,
je dis au Premier ministre et je dis au
gouvernement, asseyez-vous, respectez
les élections, ce n'était pas moi qui disais, asseyez-vous,
l'horrible monsieur peut terminer son
argument, nous n'accepterons pas
d'être emmenés dans l'Union européenne
et  Je dis au Premier ministre
de respecter la démocratie, de respecter le résultat des élections, de
respecter le droit du peuple
écossais de choisir
son avenir, nous aurons notre référendum
Premier ministre et l'Écosse restera
un
pays européen indépendant.
Le très honorable monsieur a fait référence
à d'autres
accords qu'il a conclus.  en espérant imiter, il
saura que l'accord de l'UE
avec la Corée du Sud a pris huit ans
entre le début des négociations et sa
mise en œuvre et l'accord du Canada
sept ans étant donné que le gouvernement
recherche un
accord beaucoup plus global que l'un
ou l'autre
et je lui dis  lui, la preuve sera de savoir
si
son optimisme peut être fait et ratifié
dans 10 mois.
Eh bien, nous avons déjà un accord qui
règle nos obligations financières et
prévoit des dispositions à travers le protocole
euh pour la position de l'Irlande du Nord, nous
avons donc déjà un accord
concernant la liberté  les
accords commerciaux auxquels il fait référence, il est
évidemment
plus difficile de commencer lorsque vous
concevez un prototype maintenant que ces
prototypes existent et que ce ne sont plus
des prototypes mais par priorité, il est
beaucoup plus facile de reproduire leurs
dispositions [Musique] [
Musique]
oh les filles à  blackfoot avec sa première
de ses deux questions
en blackfoot merci monsieur le président et je
voudrais commencer par
Lucas merci monsieur le président la semaine dernière les
experts en climat
[Musique]
est une tragédie
monsieur le président l'argument selon lequel au
niveau international j'utilise des diapositives comme
celle-ci pour  semaines
pour faire la comparaison internationale ne
tient vraiment pas la route
[Musique]
surprise surprise pas de Michael McCavity
et il semble maintenant qu'il
va réellement obtenir les
ruptures sans accord qu'il a toujours convoitées
ça
va être la misère la chaleur sur la misère est
recouverte de briques  apparaissent comme les
cavaliers jumeaux de l'apocalypse économique
piétinant toute perspective de reprise
et quand vous les voyez s'asseoir pour
négocier, monsieur le Président,
c'est comme regarder l'équipe B d'Écosse
affronter le Brésil des années 1970,
c'est presque cruel de les observer avec
leurs écrans de  des documents et des faits
et l'équipe GB avec leurs chaussures de clown mal ajustées
et il n'est pas possible que l'Écosse fasse
partie de ce désastre imminent.
Je regrette de devoir dire à la Chambre que
ces derniers mois,
l'UE a laissé entendre qu'elle était prête
à y aller  des mesures extrêmes et déraisonnables
en utilisant le protocole d'Irlande du Nord d'une
manière qui va bien au-
delà du bon sens simplement pour exercer un effet de
levier contre le Royaume-Uni dans nos
négociations
pour un accord de libre-échange, car en
vertu de ce protocole, cette
décision créerait une interdiction automatique instantanée et
automatique
du transfert
de nos produits d'origine animale, de la Grande-
Bretagne à l'Irlande du Nord,
aucun premier ministre britannique, aucun gouvernement,
aucun parlement ne pourra jamais accepter une telle
imposition de la part d'un homme
qui a déclaré qu'il voulait faire aboutir le Brexit
et a remporté une élection à ce sujet,
ce projet de loi annule le Brexit
en annulant  aspects clés du
protocole
qui ont été convenus, le Premier ministre a
déclaré à plusieurs reprises
qu'il souhaitait apporter l'unité au pays
au cours de son mandat.
Je le félicite donc d'avoir,
en une seule année,
uni ses cinq prédécesseurs.
Malheureusement, leur point d'accord
est qu'il  est en train de détruire
la réputation de ce pays et de
détruire la réputation
de son bureau et qu'en est-il de l'
accord commercial avec les États-Unis,
c'est ce que la présidente de la Chambre
Nancy Pelosi a déclaré: le Royaume-Uni doit respecter
le protocole d'Irlande du Nord assigné
à l'UE
si le  Le Royaume-Uni viole ce
traité international et le Brexit sape l'
accord du Vendredi Saint.
Il n'y aura absolument aucune chance qu'un
accord commercial entre les États-Unis et le Royaume-Uni soit adopté par le Congrès.
Nissan dit qu'il ne pourrait y avoir aucune garantie
quant à son plan de Sunderland s'il y avait
des droits de douane sur les échanges commerciaux entre le Royaume-Uni et l'Union européenne.
Ford a  a dit que personne ne serait désastreux, mais
vous dites que ce sera catastrophique
pour l'agriculture britannique, nous sommes dans la plus grande
crise économique depuis 300 ans,
la plus grande crise de santé publique depuis 100
ans, aucun accord n'est pas un jeu,
il s'agit des moyens de subsistance de millions
de personnes à travers le monde.  notre pays
[Musique],
je ne saurais trop insister sur mon inquiétude quant au fait
qu'un
gouvernement conservateur soit prêt à revenir sur sa
parole de rompre un accord international
signé de bonne foi
et de violer le droit international.
Je dois dire à mon honorable ami que
j'aimerais  j'aurais aimé avoir 10 livres pour chaque
fois que je lui ai cédé la place dans un débat
ou une déclaration au cours des dernières années
mais euh mais je le ferai, je lui céderai la place
à cette occasion,
je suis très reconnaissant envers ma droite  honorable
amie,
est-elle consciente que l'UE elle-même
et de nombreux autres États à travers
le monde, y compris de nombreux
pays démocratiques, ont constamment
enfreint le droit international,
laissez-moi deviner, mon vieil ami semble
dire que si quelqu'un d'autre fait
quelque chose de mal, nous pouvons le faire
quelque chose ne va pas,
je suis désolé, je ne suis pas d'accord avec lui sur
ce point,
c'est un pays qui respecte l'État
de droit,
c'est l'une des choses qui nous rendent
grands, mais on nous demande de déchirer
ce principe et de le jeter.
et pourquoi je ne peux le voir qu'à première vue,
c'est parce que le gouvernement n'a pas vraiment
compris à quoi il souscrivait
lorsqu'il a signé l'accord de retrait
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
donc
ce que nous voulions  ce n'était pas une rupture mais une
résolution
une résolution de la vieille question épineuse
des relations politiques de la Grande-Bretagne avec
l'Europe qui a tourmenté
notre histoire d'après-guerre, nous nous sommes d'abord tenus à l'écart, puis nous sommes devenus
un membre timide et parfois
obstructif
de l'UE maintenant
avec ce projet de loi  nous allons devenir un
voisin amical, le meilleur ami et allié que
l'UE puisse avoir, travaillant main dans la main
chaque fois que nos valeurs et nos intérêts
coïncident
tout en réalisant le souhait souverain du
peuple britannique
de vivre selon ses propres lois établies
par son propre parlement élu
qui  est la résolution historique
apportée
par ce projet de loi et, Monsieur le Président, je le recommande
à la Chambre.
Je voterai aujourd'hui pour ce projet de loi
visant à mettre en œuvre l'accord, car
l'alternative
est tout simplement : pas d'accord. Ce n'est pas
un vote pour savoir si nous soutenons le Brexit. Je ne le fais
pas.
mais il est arrivé qu'il s'agisse d'un vote visant à
améliorer un peu
un mauvais travail. Maintenant, il y a
des aspects
de l'accord qui seront les bienvenus.
L'absence de droits de douane
a été référée à l'accord sur les
soins de santé. Les dispositions de jeu équitable
semblent assez raisonnables.  moi et
nous avons accès à certaines des
informations dont nous avons besoin pour notre sécurité,
mais nous devons également être honnêtes sur ce qui
manque
dans cet accord et ce que cela
signifiera qu'il ne permettra pas un commerce fluide,
qu'il imposera des coûts de contrôle et des formalités administratives
Les entreprises britanniques qui exportent vers
l'Europe
n'offrent encore aucune certitude sur le transfert de données
ou les services financiers qui sont si
importants pour notre économie
et pourquoi cela s'est produit parce que dès
le début, le gouvernement a été confronté à
devoir choisir entre la
souveraineté d'une part et l'
économie.  intérêts du pays de l'
autre
et malgré tous leurs efforts pour prétendre
qu'ils pouvaient obtenir le meilleur des deux,
cela n'a jamais été
possible. Il y avait toujours un compromis.
Demain,
le processus de sortie de l'UE sera
terminé,
mais le lendemain, nous aurons besoin  regarder
vers l'avenir car une nouvelle question
nous confrontera
en tant que nation : quel type de relation
souhaitons-nous maintenant avoir avec nos partenaires commerciaux et amis les plus
proches et les plus importants
et j'espère qu'à mesure que nous allons au-delà du
congé et du maintien, nous pourrons désormais, comme
un pays pour se
réunir pour faire exactement cela
j'aime l'Europe la moitié de ma famille a travaillé
en Europe toute sa vie professionnelle j'ai
étudié là-bas
j'aime ses particularités j'aime ses
différences linguistiques j'aime les
arts, sa culture et ses habitants mais
je suis britannique
je suis membre du Royaume-Uni et je
veux les respecter,
être leur ami depuis trop longtemps, nous avons emménagé
dans la même maison qu'eux
et nous ne nous sommes pas entendus, nous allons maintenant simplement
déménager à côté
et être de bons voisins  bons amis et
bons alliés,
je félicite mon ami d'avoir
mené tout cela à une conclusion, il
mérite les applaudissements qu'il va
recevoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
notre Premier ministre un grand classique
comme son héros Périclès est le premier
citoyen de son pays et
comme lui, il a sauvé notre démocratie
comme Alexandre le Grand Boris a coupé
le nœud gordien
Churchill et Margaret Thatcher auraient
été profondément fières
de sa réussite et nous le sommes aussi
en avril 1990,
Margaret Thatcher m'a demandé de déjeuner au numéro
10 avec des membres du  le cabinet
Margaret Thatcher m'a demandé ce que je
pensais de l'Europe,
j'ai répondu au Premier ministre, votre tâche est
plus difficile que celle de Churchill,
il a été confronté à des bombes et des avions, vous
êtes confronté à des morceaux de papier,
nous avons maintenant reconquis notre souveraineté
malgré ces morceaux de papier européens que
nous avons  je dois à notre Premier ministre le pays
lui doit
nos plus sincères félicitations pour sa
réussite
Kirsten merci monsieur le Président la vérité
est qu'il y
aura une avalanche de contrôles
bureaucratiques et de formalités administratives pour les entreprises britanniques
il y aura des contrôles pour les agriculteurs pour nos
fabricants
pour les douanes sur les règles  d'origine, la
sûreté et la sécurité de la TVA, la santé des plantes et des animaux
et bien plus encore
et il est quelque peu ironique que pendant des années
le parti conservateur s'insurge
contre la bureaucratie européenne,
mais ce traité, ce traité impose beaucoup
plus de formalités administratives aux entreprises britanniques qu'il n'y en
a
actuellement et c'est le  conséquence
des choix politiques du Premier ministre,
mais il ne nous reste qu'un jour avant la fin
de la période de transition
et c'est le seul accord dont nous disposons. C'est
une base sur laquelle bâtir
dans les années à venir et finalement
voter pour mettre en œuvre ce traité est le
seul  une manière de garantir
que nous éviterons un accord nul et nous voterons donc
pour ce projet de loi aujourd'hui,
merci
[Musique]
donc [
Musique]
donc
[Musique]
vous